thank you dear journalists for joining
us remotely for this press conference
following the European Council meeting
we are joined in Zagreb by Prime
Minister plank which I hope is connected
now
and I give the floor first to the
council president good afternoon
everyone we have today the occasion to
have this video conference at the level
of the European Council and as you know
the main topic was the MFF and the
recovery fund it was the first occasion
to discuss at the level of the leaders
of the proposals put on the table by the
Commission the MFF and the recovery fund
it was the occasion to observe that
different parts there is an emerging
consensus which is very positive but at
the same time we don't underestimate the
difficulties and on different topics we
observe that it's necessary to continue
to discuss this video conference was
important was essential because the
first three weeks after the publication
of the proposals of the Commission we
had the occasion to consult the Member
States to make the clarity about the
interpretation of those proposals now we
shift to another phase we will negotiate
and I welcome the readiness to English
I'm totally committed to start
immediately real negotiations with the
Member States and we intend to have a
physical summit in around the middle of
July in Brussels and we will have the
occasion to focus on some concrete
proposals before this summit I will put
on the table some concrete proposals in
order to try to take a decision we are
aware that is essential to take a
decision as soon as possible we
had also the occasion of Sula and myself
to give a debrief after the high-level
meeting that we had at the beginning of
this week with Boris Johnson about
brexit and as you know during this
meeting we repeated the mandate that we
have decided at the European level
we will pit it that we are committed in
order to reach an agreement but not at
any cost we consider for example the
trashman's like the level playing field
like the governance like also the
protocol regarding Ireland and Northern
Ireland are very essential topics in our
opinion and we took note that for the UK
they don't have the intention to ask an
extension of the transition period it
means that we need to intensify the
negotiations we trust
Michele value and we will have the
occasion to come back at the level of
the point until later on this important
topic
we had also the occasion to have a
debrief of Angela Merkel regarding the
implementation of the Minsk agreements
and it reads that now the council can
proceed with the wall over of the
sanctions and finally I would like to
congratulate under - plenty of each the
rotating presidency by Croatia was not
an easy task because of this exceptional
circumstances that we faced together and
that we are facing and I would like to
congratulate him for his leadership for
his creativity for his flexibility we
had with ocula with anglish a perfect
cooperation and thank you for that it's
a great job you played the unrest a very
essential role in different topics
especially regarding this enlargement
discussion and the possibility to find
an agreement at the level of the
European Council on this important
strategic topic thank you for that and
thank you
Commission president please take the
floor yes thank you so much and also
from my part many many many things to
the Croatian presidency these were
challenging times they have been
outstanding and mastering an
unprecedented task in these crisis times
so many thanks from my part too it was
wonderful to work together and of course
we're looking forward to intensive work
in the council but thanks very much for
this presidency indeed today's council
came at a crucial time we are only now
six months away from the end of the
brexit transition period and it was
therefore important to take stock of the
ongoing negotiations with a United
Kingdom we joined jointly stressed our
willingness to undertake all possible
efforts to come to an agreement
seeking solution that will allow us to
sign a one-of-a-kind partnership with
the United Kingdom and indeed for this
we have to bridge white divers wider
divergences which remain to be solved
the topics are known it's the level
playing fields at the fisheries the
governance and it's the scope of our
police and judicial cooperation these
important points for the European Union
because these are principles fair
competition the rising social standards
protecting our citizens and the rule of
law these are principles that are at the
heart of the European Union
time is short however and even if we
find the deal many things will still
change in our relationship with United
Kingdom for citizens for businesses for
administration's we therefore also need
to plan for these changes the Commission
has been working on these issues we've
made progress but we should not reduce
our efforts we will continue to assist
national authorities and other
stakeholders in that preparation for
brexit I also emphasize to leaders that
we must continue
work to ensure the proper implementation
of the withdrawal agreement we will
remain very attentive on this point
finally no one can say with certainty
where these negotiations will be at the
end of this year but I know for sure
that we will have done everything to
reach an agreement and to have a good
start with the United Kingdom as a third
country neighbor then on next generation
you just like we are six months away
from the end of the transition period we
are now also six month away from the end
of the current mff and in the midst of
the deepest economic crisis provoked by
covered 19 it is therefore essential
that we lose no time in setting our
economic and social recovery on a firm
footing and as you know the Commission
has come forward with a plan to do just
that it's called next generation EU
combined with a reinforced mff it will
provide the necessary means one thousand
eight hundred fifty billion euros and
the proper focus on a green digital and
resilient recovery to help the European
Union its citizens with businesses to
emerge stronger from the crisis the
first discussion was in my view very
positive leaders unanimously agreed that
the severity of this crisis justifies an
ambitious common response one that
combines solidarity investment and
reforms and I was also glad to hear that
many leaders stress that we must do
everything in our power to reach an
agreement soon in the European Council
before the summer break there is real
understanding that the effectiveness of
the report response depends on this too
finally there was a lot of support for
the focus on the green
and the digital dimension that was very
good those as driving elements for the
modernization efforts financed by
next-generation EU all this is good news
of course the discussions also showed
differences of opinion on various issues
for example the overall size of
next-generation EU on the balance
between grants and loans on the
allocation key and unknown new resources
and rebates it is absolutely legitimate
to discuss all of these issues and I
explained to leaders
the Commission's reasoning on each of
them so I look forward to the next steps
in the discussions that channel will
organize in the coming weeks I am sure
that on these points we can reach a
consensus provided we do not lose sight
of the big picture thank you madam
president moving now to Zagreb for Prime
Minister Glenn Kovich thank you very
much and Cheryl and final opportunity
for me as the prime minister of a
country that had the privilege to be
rotating presidency during last six
months and to summarize briefly the few
essential points we try today presented
to the heads of state and government who
took part at yet another video
conference of the European Council in
the course of the Croatian presidency my
general comment is that we really had an
exceptional exceptional extraordinary
presidency due to the covered 19
pandemic which has completely altered
the methodology of the functioning of
the council unfortunately as of first
days of March we had to stop with
physical meetings at the political level
in Brussels in Luxembourg and then even
in Strasbourg for a while of course we
as Croatia are really unhappy that we
couldn't oast
many of our friends and colleagues from
the EU member-states at more than 250
events meetings conferences that we
planned to organize during this first
half of 2020 in Croatia
however our moto of the presidency was a
strong Europe in the world of challenges
when I look back at the end of October
when we presented our program I have to
admit none of us could have even
imagined that we would be faced with a
such a challenge that Europe or the
world hasn't seen for hundred years both
in terms of health issue and that is the
pandemic itself and second the
unprecedented economic and financial
consequences for the Member States for
the European Union as a whole but the
for the whole globe as well nonetheless
we tried to achieve as much as we could
and even though the situation was
aggravated in Croatia by a 5.5 Richter
earthquake that hit capital Zagreb on
the 22nd of March so we had two crises
in parallel and I am happy that we heard
a lot of solidarity from our fellow
heads of state and government on the EU
side in terms of helping us to address
the damages that amount to eleven point
five billion euros and we look forward
for the quick administration of our
application for the european union
solidarity fund in that respect what we
did is that we coordination in close
collaboration with Shar with Ursula
uncoded 19 with the integrated political
crisis response already at the end of
January then further on in a number of
meetings that were organized literally
in every single formation of the council
through a videoconference what I am
pleased that we managed to attain is the
adoption of the coronavirus response
investment initiative as well as the
sure mechanism which will both together
with the amended
budget for 2020 and the activated
general escape clause of the EU fiscal
framework enabled the enabled European
Union to react quickly and extend a
helping hand to the member states
immediately I think we made progress on
the public procurement when it comes to
the medical equipment we were very
pleased that we took care and jointly
repatriated 650,000 citizens of the EU
Member States from across the globe in
the midst of the crisis that we
completely managed to ensure the orderly
breaks it in January that we adopted a
mandate for the new relation and you
just heard Orsola
and showed how the progress is currently
ongoing we hope to find a good framework
for future relations with United Kingdom
what I am particularly personally
pleased that we managed to put back on
the agenda the dossie of the enlargement
we unblocked the very pessimistic
situation of October 2019 and the
Council passed the decision to open the
accession negotiations with North
Macedonia and Albania we hosted although
in a video conference the Zagreb summit
20 years after the first summit and I
think the messages which were sent to
the six Croatia's neighboring countries
with the Zagreb declaration are
encouraging for their future reforms and
the EU oriented efforts we also
organized together with Cheryl the
Eastern Partnership summit yesterday
this was another important message to
those six countries with varying
ambitions visually the EU approach we
had a number of conclusions that the
secretarial councils external relations
councils but what I am really keen on
attaining next week is the final
agreement among the EU Member States on
the mandate for the conference on the
future of Europe I think now more than
ever we need to agree on the frame of
this conference together with European
Parliament
and European Commission and make a quick
kickoff event in order to debate the
European project together with our
citizens because after such a crisis I
think that the thought of political
debate is very much needed what I would
like to compliment is to Ursula for her
courage and the leadership with the
proposal that she put on the table a few
weeks ago about the recovery plan I
think as much as every single government
in our member states try to step forward
in the context of this crisis visibly
the private sector with with the
businesses with already workers in our
countries I think with this message of a
recovery plan with 750 billion euros and
the rightly devised balance between the
grants and loans that the Commission is
really trying to extend a helping hand
in the immediate years post covered 19
in order to allow the recovery of
European economies Croatia is supportive
of this proposal and I'm encouraged by
the total table which are organized
today and I look forward for reaching
the agreement as soon as we can come to
terms with all member states regarding
the both multi-annual financial
framework for next seven years and the
recovery plan which would enable us to
work hard together next four years final
point on Croatia I'm very pleased that
despite the fact that it was a tough
year we managed to fulfill all the
criteria and our action plan for the
Exchange Rate Mechanism - accession
which is the antechamber for the
eurozone and we look forward for the
decision on our application in July I
thank very much charlie and Orsola for
excellent cooperation throughout these
six months and my best wishes to Angela
who will take over on behalf of Germany
as the next president
as of 1st of July thank you very much
and greetings from Zagreb Thank You mr.
prime minister from Zagreb first a point
on logistics can the technical team
inside the house please make sure that
the volume is raised sufficiently we
have a lot of participants we won't be
able to take all questions but we'll
start first with Susanna fleshes please
Susanna could you give your question and
clearly address to whom you want to
state your question to I thank you I was
not expecting my question to be the
first because actually I would like to
ask the leaders also discussed the
question regarding the internal borders
because we see some decisions recently
princess Denmark closed the doors to
Portugal also other countries did the
same so I'd like the parrot to ask to
the President of the European some the
discrimination here and when she expect
this situation of course borders to
specific countries to come to an end and
also to the President of the European
Council if this was discussed thank you
so this is we have very clear guidelines
and how to proceed till the end of the
month we expect the internal borders to
be lifted and there is a very clear
pattern that has been set out also
brought through the Council of the
ministers who are responsible for the
border management at different meetings
the last tweets in order to tackle this
important topic and did we encourage all
the Member States to cooperate in order
to try to develop a more common approach
and I am pleased to to observe that we
are lifting the restrictive measures and
I hope that it will be possible in the
next days in which we should continue to
make more progress on that thank you
next question is for Lilly bhaiyya
please could you switch on your cameras
it makes it a bit more comfortable for
us really yes I'm here if you can hear
me thank you very much I have one
question for each of the leader
for madam president my question is in
order for your proposal to work there's
a need to raise the ceiling the own
resources ceiling and that requires
every national parliament to ratify are
you confident that every national
parliament will ratify this change by
the end of the year and for president
Michelle my question is could you give
us more detail on one exactly plant the
summit in July and whether you think a
second July summit needed thank you
madam president
okay so indeed as we said the raising of
the own resources ceiling requires
unanimity in Council the consent of the
agreement of the European Parliament and
national ratification and therefore it
is so important to provide the leaders
with good and sound arguments for the
respective national parliaments to have
the debates there I think it is
appropriate to have this kind of
situation because it's a one-off it is
an extraordinary unprecedented approach
to this historic crisis and therefore
the full democratic legitimate for from
all levels is important for us I am
convinced that in all Member States as
we all suffer from this very severe
economic crisis and we know we are at
the beginning and not at the end the
understanding how important how urgent
it is for each Member States own
well-being economically and socially is
there what we want to prevent with this
unprecedented package next generation EU
is we want to prevent the unlevel of the
playing field we want to prevent the
widening of the divergences between
member states which would be a weakening
of the single market so the opposite
should be the
of our action and therefore it's in each
member state's interest to have a strong
single market a strong European Union
because we all benefit from that I would
add that this video conference was very
useful in order to identify on which
pawns we feel that we are working in the
right direction and for example we agree
that we need an exceptional response we
need the destroys is unprecedented and
that we need to to focus on the sectors
and regions which are more more affected
by the by the crisis another important
point is the fact that the proposal made
by the permission is idea that you need
to borrow at the level of the Commission
and to increase the see the ceilings of
our resources is also a positive
approach but it was also the occasion
today to observe that on some topics it
remains very complex and very difficult
it means that in the next days in
preparation of the next physical summit
we will need to work very actively on
different difficult topics like the size
the amount for the MFF and for the
recovery fund the rebates related to the
MFF the question drains versus loans the
conditionality is also a difficult topic
is that a surprise or another difficult
question is related to the criteria are
the importance for some member states of
many member states to consider that the
criteria should be more linked to the
consequences of the kava 19 we work very
hard we will try to accelerate the
negotiations in order to to have an
efficient and useful meeting in July
Thank You mr. president
going to Marco bristling now from La
Stampa Marco can you hear us yes thank
you
you said that you will put on the table
concrete proposal in the coming weeks
could you elaborate a bit more on which
point will I mean for some member states
that the total size of the recovery from
750 videos and 500 billions of grants
untouched post do you think that to
change it's not my intention to
negotiate through the press but of
course I've explained what are the
difficult topics and it means if we are
current that we need to tackle the
difficult topics and to be innovative to
be creative in order to be able to to
support with 27 member states a common
approach to take a common decision it
will be difficult it will be complex and
I don't underestimate the task but I
felt today comment too and political
will to engage which is very positive
Thank You mr. president we'll take one
more question from Sam Fleming from the
Financial Times thanks a lot could I go
back to the allocation key which you
mentioned ask both presidents whether
you see scope for a compromise on the
allocation key because as you said there
are some member states which were quite
concerned that the allocation key really
isn't related to the crisis itself it's
using economic indicators which predate
the crisis by several years in some
cases on the unemployment one is there a
way the Commissioner can rework these
allocation criteria to make them more
relevant to the crisis without
alienating at least some of the member
states in doing so thank you yes it's
right it's one of the difficult topics
and you are right for some member states
it's important to have
to have a clear link between the data
that we will use related to the Wicker
refund at the distribution of money
through the Recovery Fund and the
consequences of the Kravitz 19 and
certainly one of the pounds that we need
to tackle in the next days and weeks so
indeed what the allocation key is
concerned there have been discussions
like on other topics I think here is
important the way we approach it first
of all we've done other simulations for
example with the spring economic
forecast and you see there is no
significant change in the allocation of
the means so this shows that it is very
plausible what is it composed of there
are many variables in that a strictly
linked to crisis phenomena but the
variable in question is often why are
you relating to the last five years of
unemployment rates and if you look at
the effects of the crisis you see that
the negative effect the damaging effect
was of course prominent
in member states that were not resilient
enough in the overall structure to
absorb the shock of the crisis and
therefore rightly so in the discussion
with the leaders there was a strong
demand to take the funds of next
generation you not only to address the
crisis acute crisis elements like in the
health sector for example but to address
through investment with reforms the deep
relying sources of the lack of
resilience in member states who then had
a worse outcome outcome from the crisis
and if you link these two things the
rivals of the crisis itself the health
effect but also the vulnerability of
economies being exposed to the shock and
the inability to absorb
this shocked this is very well
represented in the unemployment rate
over the last years and therefore we had
this combination I think it's worth to
go in detail in explanations with the
member states on that again so that
there's transparency and understanding
why the things as I just described this
is one of the important topics to
discuss thank you madam president
this concludes our press conference for
today good afternoon to you all and see
you soon
[Music]
you